this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create actual real amazing
relationships
life as it's supposed to be done we
invite your calls today ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show where he talks about work
and about career every day is here as my
co-host today on the ramsey show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five lynn is with
us lynn is in tulsa oklahoma how are you
lynn
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so uh several months ago my kids and i
and my husband were in a car in an
accident and we are getting a settlement
my kids especially
are going to be getting
a good settlement and i'm wondering what
is the best way to go about saving match
okay um are are they
is everybody okay
yeah yeah um
i'm glad so there's is there any ongoing
medical need
or uh future surgeries that we need to
set money aside for
surprisingly no go ahead okay
all right and so what is the uh what do
you think the size of this is going to
be what have they indicated
um
my youngest child is going to be getting
a
about
a hundred thousand and then we have
about 50 000 in medical bills
for him for him
and then the other kids it's to be a
couple thousand
okay
but is he is he got a permanent
situation from this or
no it was just um
when it happened
my kids like my kids are here because it
wasn't their time to go like i believe
that
and we were really yeah we were really
blessed it was auto it was a pedestrian
auto accident
um
and
my kids were we were the pedestrians and
um
but your baby got a hundred i had fifty
thousand dollars in medical bills but
it's completely healed
yes wow thank you lord okay yeah it
doesn't make sense to the world but i
know it wasn't his time to go yeah i i'm
i'm more than comfortable with that and
i'm also glad for him and you yeah this
is but i just i'm thinking about how to
allocate the money so the bottom line is
we don't need to allocate the money for
anything you've already covered the 50
000 medical bills or the 50s coming out
of this hundred that's coming out of
100. okay all right and the others are
gonna get a handful of dollars all right
now yeah this is coming through an
attorney in a settlement process i
assume
correct okay
in more cases than i like the court will
dictate to you what you can invest this
in
i don't like it because i think the
parent should be allowed to decide what
to invest for their own child instead of
the judge being the parent but a lot of
judges will take the position that the
parents are idiots and so they must be
prote they must be the child must be
protected from their idiot parents
investment um i disagree with that on a
lot of levels uh morally legally and
everything else but it doesn't matter
the judge may tell you you have to put
it in something stupid like just a cd
it may not even keep up with inflation
if you do that okay
if you have the option
this child is not going to need this
money until they're grown
no he's not then i would set the money
aside in a mutual fund i'd get with a
smartvestor pro and pick a series of
mutual funds it's how i invested my own
kids money that i invested for their
college so why wouldn't i invest this
kind of money there
where it came from doesn't matter what
matters is that they don't need it for
20 years
or so
and what matters is that um
you know we need to outpace inflation
right
right and
i know you know with interest to
hopefully you know he'll have a good
chunk when he's 18 because he's only two
now so he has several years
and so i'm trying to also figure out how
to best teach him
to use it wisely so he doesn't turn you
know get it when he's a certain age and
be dumb yeah don't don't number one
don't let him be surprised that it's
there
um it's like sex don't wait till they're
20 to tell them
exactly because they'll mess the whole
thing up you know and so we need to talk
about it age-appropriately we don't slam
a three-year-old with too much
information
right right but we do teach a
three-year-old something's happening
right there's something there and so
money we're going to teach the kid how
to handle money because we expect them
to have some by the way we're gonna do
that with all your kids
this is what rich people do they teach
kids how to handle money age
appropriately we don't make the
five-year-old go to the salt mines but
we do teach them to work because they
need to call ken coleman for a career
later right that's right absolutely and
i think i think dave i think this is
great advice too is as you walk him
along and the others uh you know at some
point they may talk and he got more of a
settlement than they did so i think this
is you know telling everybody in the
kids this is not some big secret this
was something that happened because what
you don't want is resentment
to grow either so i think this is
probably need to be more
uh transparent than normal it's the only
way extra conversations and extra
communication
shut down uh all kinds of things because
this
a horrible event and
is a is a part and the survival of it
the miraculous survival of it is uh part
of your family story now yeah and so
we're gonna tell that we're gonna tell
that story
not to continually bring up trauma but
it's uh it's god's hand on our life yeah
and it's part of the story it's part of
who we are at our house and part of it
was a little one got hurt worse and got
more money and that's just the way life
worked
and so yeah you go ahead and talk about
that i wouldn't surprise the siblings
either that he's getting some money when
he gets there or she gets there right
we've already told him you know where
you guys will be getting some money but
we're not yeah we don't need to talk
about it look we didn't talk about what
the ramsey net worth was until our kids
were grown and we started talking about
estate planning with them
you know like when they were in college
we started talking about it but we you
know they knew we had some money but i
didn't want them running around school
going mud there are those bigger net
worth and you're dead and the community
we live in that's kind of a thing so um
you know i i yeah i just want to think
we know we're just working stiffs and we
are working stiffs we just did really
well and so i wanted but i wanted them
to feel the responsibility of it after i
had built their character on saving
giving working spending wisely
throughout their whole years so by the
time i turned this on and we started
that meeting with as for me and my house
we serve the lord so this is actually a
responsibility to manage god's resources
for his glory it is not you hit the
lotto
and so when they see the number they
actually kind of felt the weight of the
number
uh instead of
uh woohoo
i i can be in a reality show now that's
right i'm stupid and my parents have
money and so you know uh that kind of
stuff right and so they
didn't they didn't have that reaction
and none of my three did but again it
was a gradual increased
process through the years so i would
invest it in mutual funds and i would
you know just
age appropriately begin to reveal that
it's there to where by the time we get
there you're not afraid he's going to go
crazy or she's going to go crazy and
head off to
the caribbean and do cocaine or
something because he suddenly got a
bunch of money i mean it's just you know
we're going to fix all this ahead of
time
so my friend andy andrews says we're not
raising kids to be great kids we're
raising kids to be great adults
and that's really the target here that's
where we're going
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
well when it comes to the economy
there's always a lot of um
feelings
a lot of emotions
fear anger
shock
dismay when i filled up my raptor the
other day i kind of passed out in the
parking lot and
woke up woke up a little bit later
that's so true rachel was standing over
me making fun of me talking about her
tesla so i don't know but it's um yeah
oh man uh it's scary out there see i got
my real estate license 44 years ago so
i've seen a lot of emotion yeah over the
years
uh i got my license in 78 jimmy carter
was helping us with interest rates they
went to 19
it's 18 fixed uh by the time i'm selling
real estate in the 80s they're coming
back down to 14 in 1982
and we thought that was good
um so i've seen a lot of
uh end of the world predictions that
didn't come true
and uh chicken little has always been
alive and well and he's alive right now
people are going crazy out there some of
y'all are scared to death and if you're
under 35 truthfully this is your first
big financial thing
because the last one was 2008 and you
were a teenager
and so uh this is your first time to
actually kind of get the gut punch of
what inflation or recession or gas
prices or real estate uncertainty feels
like so we're going to help you we're
going to walk you through
what is really going on not not your
broke brother-in-law that's got the
conspiracy theories feelings about the
crash of the real estate world because
of fiat money or something we're going
to actually talk through
real estate data and what's really going
on and how real estate prices where they
come from it's a free
free live stream called the real estate
reality check it's this thursday night
rachel cruz george campbell and i are
going to do this
and we're going to show you how the
market actually works and then you can
decide for yourself but you need to be
dealing with facts not feelings
and fear is not a fact
fear is a feeling
and we all have fear we all have
uncertainty and you're uncertainty
usually um think about it the first time
you drove a car
how scared you were
death grip on the wheel because you're
uncertain you didn't know how to do it
now you drive a car with your knees put
on your makeup and eat your big mac on
the way to work right and so
but you because you've you're you know
you've gotten comfortable with the
process that's right and you know
perspective
of time and experience
gives you actual facts and data
that says okay i can walk
because sometimes people die in cars
but it's the trade-off's not worth it
it's it's a long walk so i'm going to
take the chance i'm going to drive the
car it's not that big a risk so this is
the thing about investing you got to get
used to the ride and you got to know
what you're doing and feel it and
instead of just going on feelings so
real estate reality check this coming
thursday july the 14th uh rachel george
and i go to ramseysolutions.com to sign
up it is a free
live stream
ramsey ramsay solutions.com reality
check the real estate reality check be
sure and tune in uh we're doing this
just as a service just to let you guys
know long form discussion charts and
graphs and stuff stuff i don't usually
do yeah it's because it borders on
boring
yeah but it's going to calm a lot of
people down that's why people really
need to check this out by the way your
friends and family who are telling you
all this scary stuff tell them about it
as well send them a link let them jump
in and get something that they don't see
on broadcast news all the time speaking
of data dave uh we saw job numbers from
june come out the economy added 372 000
more jobs so we're still waiting to see
are we in a recession are we not the
people need to relax because even if we
see the gdp
uh slow into where we are in a recession
we are still seeing a very hot job
market well i would have been wrong then
if because i predict i predict a
recession a light one yeah but i think
the economy is going to shrink two
quarters in a row and shrinking two
quarters in a row is a recession it's
not the end of the world and we might
see just a slowing down of that's the
craziness i mean because people came out
of their caves after covid you know like
a baptist after a casserole i mean they
bought everything
in sight they started buying stuff hand
over fists and the factories hadn't been
making nothing and so the prices went up
on everything it drove inflation crazy
and you can blame joe biden but it's not
all his fault part of it's his fault but
it's you know it's not i mean if you
watch fox news though everything's his
fault but um
but the uh if you watch cnn nothing's
his fault and they're still talking
about trump
that's all they talk about everything
but but bottom line is it's trump's
fault yeah that's whose fault it is i
don't know how but it is probably
reagan's fault actually
clinton that's who we should blame sure
but um but yeah and the truth is none of
them have as much control as everybody
like think they do but they can do some
stupid stuff like cut off the gas supply
and drive grass prices oh sure that one
was stupid but um but the the a lot of
this other inflation stuff is coveted
based that's because of demand yeah and
so that's driving this job market thing
man i'm telling you i you know we we
took some time off for our 40th
anniversary last week
and you know uh we're in a resort
setting beautiful area they're having
trouble getting people to work that's
correct still
still labor shortages we're still seeing
more jobs created the pandemics spun off
a lot of new jobs and a lot of people
went on their own that's true a lot of
entrepreneurs and so again here's the
point what we're going to see in the
real estate reality check the live
stream you're going to see really good
data you're going to see encouragement
in in a major part of this economy and
that's real estate and i'm telling you
in the job part of things we are still
in a historic
job economy we are 3.6
unemployment that is the same number
that we were in
february of 2020 this is right before
everybody went home for a season when
the pandemic hit in march and it was the
economy was quite hot then and it was
and so we saw a lot of people lose their
jobs and just to give people perspective
here uh we're seeing now the
unemployment rate back down to
pre-pandemic levels so this guy did you
see that coming i thought i thought
employment was going to cool off
uh well two things i did see i did see
that we would come out of this pandemic
where we had a lot of people i mean in
the la in the last 90 days i thought it
was going to come down
yes because we did see a lot of layoffs
in in may yeah it was reported big time
companies you know that was the pre you
know the pre uh condition for the
research second quarter that's right
leading into the recession and and this
indicates i might be wrong that there
might not be a recession well because
companies don't hire big time in a
recession they do not and so i think
you're going to see parts of the economy
will we might technically see a
recession i'm studying a lot of
economists right now they're still
waiting to see i think your prediction
is going to be right i think we'll see
an actual small recession of the gdp but
that can be true at the same time we see
companies laying people off we saw big
tech lay a bunch of people off in may as
a reaction to
a slow down in consumer spending amazon
announced layoffs really yes uh yeah in
the last two weeks but that's because
inflation fears are naturally bringing
people the everyday consumer the
american family that we talk to day in
and day out they are spending less we
are see consumer spending drop but it
doesn't mean that you'll see layoffs
happen in a healthy economy and you'll
see people add jobs so what we're seeing
now dave is a little bit of a reset and
a return to a normal job economy where
some companies and industries will lay
off others will increase so for instance
i think you're going to see in the
construction and manufacturing spaces a
lot of jobs added and we saw that in the
june job report because now things are
starting to heat up again well that's
encouraging because that's various
people who make things yeah and see
you're going to share this i'm sure in
the real estate reality check event
we've been talking about but a healthy
construction and housing start economy
is always good when we see good things
there we see good economic indicators so
i just think to your point let's focus
on the facts
and not the headlines that are designed
to get you to click on them designed to
get you to snap your neck in the living
room and keep watching so
if the jobs report came in that positive
yeah um
[Music]
in fact the only area that contracted
dave were government jobs oh darn i
don't appreciate you killing me here i
knew you'd appreciate it to which we all
said thank you lord but yeah uh and the
congregation said amen but the uh all
right so
because the great resignation was both
an accident existential thing where
people got the crap scared out of them
i'm gonna die someday so i'm not gonna
work a job i hate yes so i'm gonna quit
this job and go do something else that's
that was an element of it but another
element of it was there was such a
shortage of labor they could go they
could anywhere they wanted to go and do
anything they wanted to do and it also
spurred up this uh home home school on a
homeschool work from home stuff that's
right and uh
uh that
you know people were tolerating anything
just to hire people that's correct in
terms of you work wherever you want just
help me i need some help and that kind
of thing and uh
some wonder i was wondering i kind of
had the hope that that was all cooling
off but if this job reports heating up
then that stuff may still rock on for a
while
we may be sitting in that all summer
you're going to see the great
resignation the job continue because we
saw may's numbers 392 000 jobs were
added june 372. so you're looking at uh
you know almost 800 000 jobs in the last
two months
things aren't as bad as the news would
believe lead you to believe yeah there
it is real estate reality check you
gotta check it out it's gonna be a great
event
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
join us anytime in the lobby at ramsey
solutions so there's all kinds of things
to do here it's kind of a visitor center
almost
including watch
watching ugly paint dry us do the show
for three hours every day we're here
from one to four central everyday live a
couple of us ramsey personalities doing
it every day
and with very rare exceptions obviously
holidays and things we're not here but
come in there's a homemade chocolate
chip cookies and coffee and it's all
free and
there's usually 50 to 200 folks hanging
out out here also included in the lobby
is the debt free stage and jeremy and
heather are on that hey guys how are you
what's happening dave
where do you guys live we live down the
road in columbia dave oh right down the
road neighbors in huh mule town very
cool good to have you
so how much should pay off 50 000. all
right how long did that take about 23
months good for you and your range of
income during that time it was about 83
to about 1 30. very cool what do y'all
do for a living i work at uh pinnacle
bank in franklin so i work in loan
operations yeah really good job very
thankful for it good people we bank with
them yeah really good people you don't
see me in the loan operations side but
yeah but the rest of the rest of it's
awesome
i'm a national account manager for an
outdoor power equipment company oh great
very cool good for y'all all right so
what kind of debt was this 50 000
let's see it was a variety of stuff dave
medical debt irs stuff um student loans
student loans medical bills cars
court stuff from my first divorce yes
y'all were kind of normal yeah
yeah how long you been married two and a
half years okay so you get married and
you say okay
one of the things we're gonna do
immediately 23 months right you must
have started almost immediately tell me
your story what happened
well basically jeremy started telling me
the dave ramsey story when we first met
jeremy is very um very good with
finances and um i myself was not and so
it took a lot of encouragement
well previous to the bank i waitressed
and bartended and so you know there was
a lot of cash there was no bank account
there was no budgeting i actually didn't
even really comprehend what budget
entailed and so
when we first met you know
shortly after we started talking about
finances and the idea of the budget and
so it took a very long time for me to
get on board i was what you call
budget-ish i said we can do a budget-ish
but yeah we i would really wonder
he wasn't going with that budget was a
four-letter word for a while so how did
you break your foot no i'm kidding
that's a whole nother story
that's an ultimate frisbee story yes
okay i wish it was cooler than that it
was actually my tilly's achilles tendon
unfortunately so
hey how that hurt just hearing it anyway
okay so so you're newly married and you
don't even know what a budget is you
said you're budget-ish and so you break
it to her and you seem like a free
spirit is that is that fair heather
so
how how how tense was it when you really
started to lock in on this was it really
hard it was horrible like i remember the
thing that actually set me on the right
track was i actually watched rachel and
i watched her talk about when her and
winston first sat down to do a budget
and she rolled her eyes and she said oh
you're one of those people and so i
think watching rachel there was
something where i connected with her and
i connected with what she was saying and
so that kind of made me want to go ahead
and take the plunge
but every budget meeting it was kicking
dragging screaming
three months it took us four months
before i understood that when you have a
budget that means you don't go over it
means you actually stay under this
designated amount you just thought it
was a suggestion yeah yes
yes
rachel is the nice ramsay she is and a
free spirit so i could see how you
connected with her like if rachel can do
it
yeah sure yeah and poor jeremy was like
he is amazing he's been so patient and
he's been so kind and he's had so much
grace and so
um it's really been a journey and it's
really been a journey for our marriage
too um you really get to know one
another and you really get to you really
push yourselves and you kind of see what
you're made of and you learn how to work
together and so
it's been amazing yeah
good very good
very very cool okay now you did it fifty
thousand and twenty three months so now
we can spend lots of money right
like that
no now you get to still be a grown-up
and you decide you're going to spend
lots of money you don't need my
permission to do it you get to do
whatever you want to do
between you two i'll let you guys figure
that part out but yeah
so what is the secret to paying off 50
grand in 23 months
um it's a few things dave i think it's
being the budget is of course
you have to do the budget right um every
month is really different yeah so i mean
different things happen month in month
out so you have to do it every month um
i think consistency intentionality
um and really one thing that
that really
for us was was from day one when we
decided to do this
um you know we both know what it was
like to struggle you know heather
you know into her like so we got married
in our early 40s yeah so she knew what
it was to struggle like i said i had a
previous marriage i know it's like to be
a single dad struggling
um
and coming together and having two
incomes
um was a blessing
it that was a blessing but then we also
we decided from day one you know as we
do this plan we're gonna start tithing
every
every paycheck you know okay um
and that's been i mean that's been a
game changer yeah
honestly we wanted to make sure that we
made mention of that and talked about
the tithing because you know we know
that everything we get comes from god
and so to be in a place where we have
two incomes where we're able to give
back and i have you know i have a list
of probably i don't know 20 animal
organizations that we're going to give
to when we can when we get to that step
but giving back to god is like the most
important thing for us and so we wanted
to make sure that that was something
that we mentioned today yeah and he
blessed us along the way a lot yeah for
sure it was amazing i already know the
answer i think but i'm curious as to
your take on it why do you think it is
that when you start tithing it changes
everything
go ahead
um i think number one it
number one you're acknowledging that
like i said everything comes from him
yeah um exactly number two i think it
starts instilling
generosity so i mean even above tithing
there were
times um throughout those couple years
um you know maybe our church was raising
money for something
you know something specific and we were
able to give and do that or help out you
know some individuals along the way
when we could so it's just i think it's
just about a posture of your heart and
yeah and it's about yeah it's a posture
of your heart and it's giving you know
everything good we have comes from god
and the reason why we're both standing
here and we've been through every trial
and tribulation we have is because god
has brought us through it and god has
always been good and so for us to be
able to be good to god like it's the
right thing to do it's biblical and it
yeah i think just having a posture of
your heart that instills giving like
it's just a beautiful thing and so we
just love the fact that that money goes
to the church and it goes to food banks
and it goes to
you know it filters out to people who
really need it
very good well done you guys well done
yeah yeah when you there's something
about when you take your eyes off
yourself
the posture of your heart and you put
your eyes on other things other people
other
others there's a nobility to that that
changes who you are and then you don't
whine as much about something in the
budget yeah it just it changes that
i didn't say i didn't say i said as much
he said as much i didn't say not at all
because
we all reserve a little room for some
budget whining yeah okay yeah i love
more than others very transparent
heather it works but gosh it stinks
i love it good stuff you guys we're very
very proud of you congratulations thank
you very much who were your biggest
cheerleaders
we we had some friends in the church um
yeah we had some folks that worked here
that we you know knew and my parents
were very supportive along the way too
so we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you great that's the
next chapter in your story a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away and help somebody get started on
this same journey and also a one-year
subscription to financial peace
university cool and the brand new videos
that are in there and uh they'll change
everything way to go you guys awesome so
proud of y'all jeremy and heather
columbia tennessee 50 000 paid off in 23
months newly married did it with 83
making 130 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
[Applause]
that's fun
very well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today michael is in las vegas
hey michael how are you
i'm doing well how about yourself better
than i deserve what's up
all right uh so here's kind of the
rundown i am 38 i have three boys and
i'm going through the middle of a
divorce uh i'm sorry
it is what it is
um trying to make the best of it though
uh we are splitting the house though 50
50 and zillow currently has a as
estimated at uh 108 000.
um we already kind of have a buyer he
wants to bring in his own
assessor
and whatever it is and whatever price we
agree to obviously we're going to split
at 50 50.
on the low end i'm thinking it's going
to be around about 300 000 you know less
the broker fees and all that other stuff
the question is what should i do with
that
because my
dad says i should maybe get an apartment
kind of figure it out for a little bit
see how the housing market goes up and
down
i'm thinking i should buy an rv a nice
one uh roughly your data
rv's gonna go down in value
this is not the time for an adventure
you you know yeah you need to just get
calm settle down for those boys
and just settle in and then wait a year
and then buy something i'm fine with
that i think your dad's right on track
on our because man rvs are hard to sell
and they go down in value
and so you're getting really parked
your money in something that's hard to
sell and goes down in value
yeah that's true i mean i do want to get
out there and use the rv as more than
just you know something to live in
but maybe i should scale that back i'll
just go rip something taylor is it funny
just going yeah you don't have to buy
anything just go rent something
okay there's plenty of rv rental things
out there several programs out there
that you can rent if you want to go be
gone for three weeks with the boys and
just have a
you know a post-divorce healing time a
trip to
you know whatever uh yellowstone park or
the grand canyon or whatever it is
you're going to do and something where
you just spend a lot of time with them
and you're going to rent something but i
mean that's going to cost a handful of
dollars
you'll lose more than that when you
drive the new rv off the lot
okay
okay and then what so reinvest into a
house
the other thing is what should i do i
want to set up like a college fund for
the boys as well
okay um are you debt
free um i have about 6 000 in credit
cards and that's literally it okay all
right i would pay those off and cut them
up and get debit cards so that you don't
go into debt again
um i already cut those up
good you're on track okay and let's set
aside a portion are you you're getting
actually fifty thousand half of the
hundred
no no it's a three hundred thousand it's
paid for i'm getting
yeah no the house is worth about seven
oh you're getting 300.
yes oh okay all right i thought i
thought it was selling for uh some
earlier there was a hundred thousand
discussion okay anyway all right so you
got 300k that's awesome we'll set aside
a chunk for an emergency fund uh three
to six months of your household expenses
what do you make a year
uh right now i'm in between jobs i get a
stipend from the va for what would you
make when you get back to work
uh right around
thirty thousand okay so if you set aside
fifteen thousand for an emergency fund
you'll be fine if you set aside another
ten thousand for trips
and rental fees
and whatever and takes they take the
boys somewhere that'll be fine
okay okay and then you and you go
wrenching rv you've rent one forever for
ten thousand dollars oh my god
and so um
and uh uh
then we're gonna just park the rest of
it for a year and rent something
inexpensive
and just let yourself settle down and
decide
when some of the smoke is cleared out of
your brain from this you'll make a
better decision on a piece of real
estate
okay like you don't you don't want to
get remarried you don't want to get
remarried three days after you get
divorced that's called rebound and
buying a house on the rebound is also a
bad idea
okay
all right and the other thing is look uh
boys college fund you'll get it
you sit down with the smart investor pro
they'll help you park the money for the
year and get some going to kids college
and you'll have the rest of it for the
down payment on the next house
okay you make 30 000 a year how the crap
did you end up in a 700 000 house
uh her parents helped with uh some of
the payments as well
okay and they're not recouping any of
that you're still getting half the half
of it
wow what's the plan going forward for
you professionally
well initially like i said i was going
to take some of this um
money and uh invest into a business that
i was going to start
but i think
right now i think i just need to try and
figure out what i should do with with
this money and really evaluate if going
into business for myself is a
smart move or if i should just get uh
you know get back on track with a job i
would do that first so as dave was
talking about not buying a house on the
rebound
don't start a business on the rebound
get a good stable day job and as you
begin to settle into renting and settle
into parenting these boys as a single
father and all of the new things coming
your way then you begin to look towards
the future what is it that i want to do
what's the best way to do it i would
hold off on starting any business for a
while business is too hard to fall into
it yes you got to walk into it with your
shoulders square
and a resolute look in your eyes like
you're bound to determine start a
business because it's hard
it is not an easy process johnny's in
new york city hey johnny welcome to the
ramsey show
how you doing guys great man how can we
help good um i'm trying to decide if
it's a smart move to sell my paid off
car
to accelerate paying off my student loan
debt what's your car worth
so right now i could probably sell it
for about nine to ten thousand what do
you mean and i have
about eighty thousand after bonus and
how much is your student loan debt
fourteen thousand no i wouldn't sell it
how old are you
25 okay so where's all your freaking
money going
uh that's the thing yeah that's the
thing and they ain't gonna be fixed by
selling your nine thousand dollar car
you make a ton of money and you're
wasting a ton somewhere
yeah but i have been actually paying off
a lot of student debt i started with 50k
oh good okay
okay no it's it's not completely thrown
away but yeah i'm getting a little
exhausted of
you know sacrificing so much
and i don't necessarily need my car how
much did you pay off in what period of
time
um in three years i've paid off
thirty six thousand dude you haven't you
haven't exhausted anything
yeah
okay twelve thousand dollars a year out
of eighty that's pretty wimpy you should
not be exhausted from that
yeah yeah
the job that i do have now is actually
pretty new good oh okay you weren't
making 80 the whole time i keep beating
this guy up man
then he keeps coming back well i don't
have to back off of him okay i want to
help a little bit johnny you said you
don't need the car why don't you need
the car he lives in new york city i know
but i want to hear him say it yeah i
mean i i think i i commute to work
without my car yeah so you literally
don't need it at all i mean if you were
to remove it today
uh would it change your habits of
transportation getting in and out of the
city not at all correct no no it
wouldn't um i think it's just more a
luxury item to go like visit family or
friends i would sell it
i would dave i would sell it in his case
because it's gonna fast forward the
process if he gets nine or ten for it
now he's got five left he's still he can
pay it off quickly i'm game with that
but johnny let's make sure we do get to
the bottom of you don't have to do it
with me but you got to do it with a guy
in your mirror you need to get to the
bottom of what well you you kind of
indicated
that you've uh in one sentence you were
sacrificing deeply and you're exhausted
in another sentence you were talking
about how sloppy you were and that you
could do more so i'm not sure where you
are
and so i was trying to pick on you and
then i couldn't pick on you and i can't
figure out what to do so i'm trying to
help you but
the point being i want you to look in
your mirror and go okay what do i need
to do as a 25 year old man
i need a man up here and what have i got
to do to be grown up and handle my money
with a diligence
in a way that that feels very dignified
and noble because i'm being such an
adult about it and i'm not partying my
life away or i'm not disorganizing and
and being sloppy because if making 80
grand you ought to pay off 14 in a
heartbeat that's right okay that's the
thing i'm hearing but you just started
making that and then parts of it you
were sacrificing in parts of it you
weren't so you got to figure that out
but i don't want you to sell the car and
still not face the guy in your mirror
so sell it that's fine but only if you
look at the guy in the mirror and tell
him he needs to straighten up
because that changed my life when i did
that and i was about your age when i did
that and i'm a multi-millionaire now
because i did that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth
find work and do work that they actually
love
and create amazing relationships ken
coleman ramsey personality host of the
ken coleman show is my co-host today
he's also a number one best-selling
author and expert in the worlds of
career and work we're here to help you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five al and
raleigh starts off this hour hey ali al
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you i got i got raleigh
and ally all tied up there for a second
so i'm beautiful man how can i help
all right so i'm calling because
um
well it's career advice i i got out of
the military uh last year and since then
i've been in between a few jobs i'm
currently working as a trucker now and
i'm a full-time
college student i'm going to school
online about halfway through with that
i'm on baby steps four five and six
thank you for that
and um
basically i'm having a lot of self-doubt
and kind of falling
out of love with my degree program and
more in love
with my job right now
and
i
don't know which one i should pursue
more heavily if i should
buckle down and and keep going
with finish up my degree and you know
hope i fall back in love with
the program what's the degree my career
what's the degree direction
electrical engineering interesting and
you've fallen in love with trucking huh
driving the truck
i have um i'm for i'm very fortunate
right now to be working
um
a local position so i don't have to go
over the road or nothing uh monday
through friday
you know reasonable times see the family
on the weekend so so what's
unfortunately yeah so that's a that's a
pretty all-inclusive gig in the truck
and you either love that or you hate it
i don't find a lot of guys that are
middle ground on that and i think that's
really interesting
i think you have to listen to that the
question i have is if you were to slow
down you're halfway through i'm assuming
you got the gi bill so you're not paying
out of pocket for the degree correct
that's correct and you chose electrical
engineering i'm wondering because maybe
you did some of that type of work in the
military or no was it just out of left
field
no no um so prior to the military um i
was on the robotics team in high school
and i really enjoyed it yeah um but
after doing 11 years in the infantry i
kind of i got tired of being a dumb
grunt and i want to go back and use my
brain but right um
it feels like things are
piling up and
like i said i'm having some self-doubt
on it so what's piling up there's the
answer what's piling up describe what
you mean
um
well as the course load gets more and
more difficult
i find myself having difficulty
concentrating on the work
but like when i'm on and the days and
the days are going well i i get it and
everything clicks and everything moves
along
but
on the days i'm not and there's quite a
lot of them um
just getting my thoughts together is
really really hard okay so what i want
you to focus then is is what led you
into the electrical engineering degree
and obviously there's something from
your past robotics you love to work with
your head and your hands you've got that
kind of wiring in your brain but it
doesn't mean
that this particular path is the best
path for you and so i would not make any
decision to walk away from the degree
right now but i would take 30 days just
as a ballpark figure to really dive into
what are some fields
that i am intrigued by i'm in i am
interested in that would involve that
type of engineering brain
that wouldn't require the degree and
that class work and that type of work
because i think there's there's some
silver lining in here and that you've
done some robotics in the past you're
intrigued on some days you're thriving
on sundays and not on others and that
could be course related and the type of
work so instead of throwing it all out i
want you to actually dive in a little
bit more and it's almost an old school
exercise i've got a pad hold on one
second dave i got a pad right here and
i'm going to go to those classes on the
days that i'm struggling i want to write
down what what's making me struggle
what's causing me to struggle and the
days that i'm thriving why am i thriving
i would dive into that a little bit more
over 30 days before deciding to get out
of the degree experience absolutely i
completely agree
um hey al when i was in college
i went to this uh i went in this one
class
and um
when i left there uh the third day uh i
felt really dumb
it was really
hard
are you struggling with that
um academically it was straining my
brain
no no academically i mean i i maintain
good grades um
but
there's just some self-doubt
creeping in just because yeah you
mentioned dumb grunt earlier
yeah
and i'm a little bit afraid i'm a little
bit afraid that that this is like your
first academic challenge and i kind of
want to encourage you to push through it
because i think you got the stuff
okay
because i think it's self-doubt i don't
think it's reality
am i wrong
no i i don't think you're wrong okay and
you may need some during the 30 days you
may need to set your study habits
pattern up better because it sounds like
your catches catch can and if you got
something that's deep and that is
scratching the back of your brain like
i'm talking about this very hard
academically it's like thick
and weighty and hard to push through
i've been in those classes and i don't
like them because it pisses me off when
i can't get something quick
and um you know if you have to do that
the only way to push through that is uh
a study habit pattern that gets you real
quiet real centered away from humans no
distractions and you push through the
concepts and get your head around them
and that's the that that's going to take
you on through the if if you got a heavy
academic thing it'll push you through
study habits will do it and the study
setting the setting and if you're trying
to do this like while you eat dinner at
the truck stop that ain't gonna work man
al i'm curious is there a job in your
mind that if we offered that to you
today we fast forwarded all the degree
stuff and you got to go do it
uh if you got something in your mind
right now would you do that over
trucking if you didn't have to struggle
through all this and all the doubt went
away and we just gave you the
opportunity to step into it
yes 100 you would 100 percent take the
elect that type of work over trucking
absolutely okay so there's the answer
yeah so there's the answer so again
yeah the exercise i gave you plus what
dave is telling you
um you have to identify what's causing
the self-doubt
and that's the source of this once we
get to the bottom of so fear is i'm
afraid something bad is going to happen
it's cousin's doubt and doubt is i don't
think something good can happen and and
that's what you're dealing with i don't
know i'm two years in i don't know that
i can get through this that anybody will
hire me because i was just a military
grunt i'm just a truck driver i think
dave that's the source it's a narrative
in al's head that he's not good enough
that's exactly that's what i was getting
at yeah yeah and you and what i'm
hearing is actually you are good enough
uh you've actually got the stuff because
you didn't tell me like there's no way i
can do this i mean you just say that
you're like i can do it yeah i'm getting
the grades i've just got to get my head
around i got to get the habits and the
rhythm you know what else you might do
you might visit someone that is actually
doing what you want to do someday spend
time with maybe say hang out with them
maybe who you're hanging out with is
telling you you can't do it
you got to be careful who you hang out
with i asked you al if we give it to you
would you take it you said 100
then go get it so go take it go get it
nobody's going to give it to you get
them get them
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
every week on our show we hear from
callers who are in the wrong career or
not using their talents it's happening
in the kin it is a lot
and uh so we as a organization dave a
couple years ago we got together we have
some smart people in this building like
really smart people and we try not to
let them on the air though
all right
and so we said we said to developers
what if we could help people identify
what they do best that's their talent uh
their top passions that's work they
really enjoy doing and then a sense of
mission meaning what motivates them what
results do you want to put out into the
world and so we put it together it's
called the get clear career assessment
and it is a wonderful tool
that takes about 20 minutes and in about
20 minutes you're going to get a very
specific report in those three areas
what are your top areas of talent what
are the top areas of passion work you
love to do and then what results
motivate you and you talk a lot about
motivation you've always said you can't
motivate wet wood you know and this is
the idea that if you're in work that
you're good at that you love and that
produces results that get you up in the
morning get you fired up uh then you've
got a great chance of not just making
great money but making great impact so
we created the assessment and tens of
thousands of people have taken it it's a
thirty dollar price point at
ramseysolutions.com
pretty simple if you do the get clear
assessment i can make you one promise
you will be clearer yeah and that leads
to confidence you know you can make the
right decision because a lot of people
they
earl nightingale used to say people
spend more time picking out a suit of
clothes than they do their career isn't
that true
and it's like they and they fret and you
know you're gonna buy a piece of
electronics you read all the consumer
reports data you do everything else you
do all this deep research to buy a
freaking stereo
or or a tv or whatever but
and then you just go why'd you take that
job my buddy said they were hiring i
can't tell you many times i first say i
fell into it i just fell into it it was
the first thing offered after college
here i am 38 years later and i've been
miserable the whole time that's the
majority of american workers yeah
yeah and no reason to be that way no no
because here's what happens your income
and your impact rise together when
you're doing what you were created to do
and so that's what the assessment does
great way for those of you that need a
bigger shovel
the reality is is to make more money to
get out of debt faster you're going to
do it by getting promoted or having to
pivot and this will help you good stuff
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they have a 100 guarantee that means
if you mess up and i have if you miss
measure and i have or you pick the wrong
color and i do they'll remake your
window blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more always use the magic word the
promo code is
ramsey today's question comes from tom
in illinois and this may be my favorite
blinds.com question of all time i listen
to the show every day he says i
appreciate how you advise people about
money but i'd like to ask dave given
your net worth dave why are you still
working
it makes the assumption that i was
working for money
that's right that's true and i quit
working for money a long time ago i make
money and i use it for keeping score
because i want to know if i won the game
but um am i actually serving because if
you serve people they'll give you
certificates of appreciation with
president's faces on them my friend
rabbi lapin says that and so um
i like keeping score but uh no i don't
you're right i'm not working because of
my net worth i'm not working because of
that working because of the impact what
you said earlier yeah the um
i mean honestly
let's just let's just be let's just be
real okay couple guys i like this okay
you ready yeah
who wouldn't like a job
who for three hours every day people
call and ask your opinion about
something it's a very good plan
where else would you get that so true
you don't get that at home no
no where else do you get this yeah it's
a it's a freaking ego stroke but i mean
you speak in front of thousands and
thousands of people you know millions
here on the air yeah and you know people
actually ask my opinion and some of them
care about it is there's the thing your
name is so first all over the building
that can't be bad walking in every day
yeah it's that don't do it that don't do
it
that gets boring fast but yeah i mean
really it's a great job well it is and
you know you talk about this all the
time i mean when we look at the problems
in our culture
um i never i never you know i've never
run into anybody in 30 years in a
restaurant that came up to me and goes
uh you know ramsay you got me out of
debt my life sucks i hate you
right that has never been said it
doesn't happen i've had people mad at me
about other things like you don't need
to talk so much about politics you're
mean on the radio i hear that i hear
that kind of stuff yeah but nobody ever
said you know you got me out of debt and
i hate you it's true it's absolutely
never got that in 30 years so
um no it's fun that's good everybody
loves to give their opinion that's why
that whole uh remember jay leno our
friend you know they used to go on
social media ask people their opinion
they'll tell you anything yeah yeah
social media is a wreck for that very
reason oh yeah gives a bunch of people
an opinion that shouldn't have one you
know it's just crazy so
that's why you do it
i like stirring up a ruckus yes all
right julie's with us in atlanta hi
julie welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you better than i deserve
what's up
uh i am currently um changing employers
so i'm leaving my current company and um
i'm over 55. my husband are fairly new
baby steps were only three months in so
we're in baby step number two
um it's my understanding that i can cash
out the 401k that's with my current
employer since i'm 55 or older
without penalty other than the taxes
that i owe
so i'm wondering if that would be a good
idea to put towards our debt snowball um
and then
the best way to break up that snowball
to have more of an effect
what do you do for a living currently
i'm a physical physical therapist
okay most of all 401ks are a 59 and a
half
i have run into one or two particular
occupations that are 55 and i don't
think you're one of them i think you
might have bad info
i don't think you can cash it out to 59
and a half
um even if you can
i'm going to tell you not to because i
have a sense that you have the income to
go ahead and clean up your debt now that
you've decided to without destroying
your retirement to do it how much is in
the 401k
um this one is only like 17 000. okay i
had i've changed jobs over the years my
husband's a football coach so we've
moved around so i have a lot of them
that i can roll in together and i just
haven't done that so
well you know i would get with a smart
vester pro and roll them all and get
them in one place so that you can manage
them in good mutual funds
and then i think you're going to find
that this 17 is going to be taxed and
penalized if it is that means it's going
to be like a 30 or 35 percent hit right
and you wouldn't borrow money at 35
interest to pay off this debt
right right so in that reason i would
roll it out i think it was yeah i would
not release
something said you could
do it at 55 but that again it might be
bad info who did who told you that
um clark howard didn't tell me that i
mean i heard on one of his okay his
radio show
clark
he may have been addressing one of the
particular occupations and there's a few
of them and i'm pretty sure you're not
it okay it's usually uh some kind of a
special school district thing
or uh maybe a railroad person something
in those areas it's not a mainline
corporate job like you've been having so
um you know clark clark's a friend of
mine he's very smart and so probably
probably who he was addressing at that
moment was in that area but most all of
them are 59 and a half so i'm going to
tell you to roll it with the others with
a smartvestor pro not into your new 401k
but into mutual funds into good
a good rollover ira into good mutual
funds alex is in boston hey alex what's
up
hey not much dave how are you doing
today better than i deserve how can i
help
all right excellent well dave so i'm on
baby steps four five and six i'm holding
no debt except for my mortgage i pay
approximately twenty six hundred dollars
per month i'm contributing 15 to my 401k
i make about 150 000 per year working as
an outside sales rep i drive
approximately 30 000 miles a year for
work now my employer provides me with a
company car i've had it for about 10
years a couple cars over 10 years and i
just received word that that benefit
will no longer be available come july
30th
wow my question is no notice
no notice it was it came as a shocker to
me actually this morning and um
my question is i have a large commission
check coming at the end of the month how
large uh give it
21k okay yeah that's probably just buy a
car with it that's what you're gonna
need to do
um
you don't want to drive too expensive a
car because whatever you drive with the
right miles you put on it you're
destroying its value
you're a road warrior and so this is a
cost of doing business so they just gave
you a pretty substantial pay cut even if
they're giving you a car allowance
they're doing this because it's good for
them
mathematically so pay cash for something
that you can wear out and that is
reasonably comfortable and reliable but
you're going to wear it out and you're
going to destroy its value so yeah 20
grand is probably max
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host on the
stage the debt free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions wayne and whitney
join us hey guys how are you you're
doing good dave good to have you guys
how much have you paid off
go ahead uh 350 000. very cool how long
did that take
uh we're a little atypical it took us
about four months
okay that works wow and uh your range of
income during that time uh 230. okay and
what do you guys do for a living oh i'm
a physician
i'm a stay-at-home mom okay so obviously
you didn't make 350 in four months so
how did you do this
what was it what kind of debt was it
uh most of it was uh student loans
obviously being a physician and uh i
guess
um we didn't really know what to do with
money so back when i graduated residency
we had uh
over six hundred thousand 000 of debt
most of it was medical school and i felt
a moral obligation to pay it off
and we were slowly chipping away at it
but we didn't have any plan or direction
and then
covet ended up hitting and fortunately
you know i work in an industry where i
was able to you know keep earning a fair
amount of money
and then um
yeah
it got to a point where i was in a toxic
work environment and i was just living
not necessarily paycheck to paycheck
because we were investing in real estate
at the same time
as being a physician and uh
i was just sick and tired of being sick
and tired as you guys always say and i
didn't want my children to have to deal
with the stress that i was bringing home
from work so
in the fall of last year we found you
guys for the first time and at that
point we had knocked it down about 350
000
but we realized if we liquidated
everything
we could pay it off really quickly yeah
everything what's your sale yeah
so i approached him and i said hey i
have this idea why don't we go ahead and
the market's really good well let's go
ahead and sell our house and move to uh
we had a rental home at the time and uh
i was like let's move back to our our
rental home and so we looked at when
that lease would end and the lease would
end actually february of 2022 so it
would end in about two months from when
i had this idea so we said this is
perfect timing let's go ahead and put
our house on the market
sell it and put that towards debt and
then we'll move into our
the at the time our rental home that
would become available
so that's what we did we put our house
on the market and we sold it we had a
con we put it on at um one night and the
next day we had a contract we sold it
and we put uh
our net profit towards the student loan
debt okay
and the the renters you are the buyer
let you stay for two months
well
no we um we sold our main home and so
the the rental contract was up in
february and we just uh told our tenant
who was a wonderful so we were able to
move directly in yeah
i got the timeline confused okay cool so
what did your house sell for
uh the net profit was about a hundred
and twenty thousand uh-huh yep and then
uh we liquidated all of our savings and
other investments because we were trying
to do the burr method uh trying to
really you know flip homes and things
like that
and so the rest came out of savings we
dropped everything down to a thousand
dollars like you were saving and
we liquidated everything except our
small home and our retirement that i
have so what was the sale price on your
home 420 000. okay and what was what is
the home you moved into worth
right now it's worth about 180. okay so
you cut in half yes value-wise a little
more than a half yeah and you liquidated
everything in sight
yes everything to be free and get your
life back oh yes definitely was it you
wouldn't be standing here if this wasn't
true but i assume it was worth it oh
totally worth it yes absolutely yes yes
we are free and we feel wonderful um you
know getting out of debt oh yeah yeah
yeah so the ramsey method
yes yes
yes
yeah we were really financially just in
the wilderness not really knowing what
to doing kind of putting money here and
there towards loans but once we came
across the ramsey method you know we got
on we're just joking with you but yeah
that's good yeah four months i thought
we would we um honestly we had talked
about our student loans and we had at
one point said are we ever going to pay
off these student loans we're going to
be paying these student loans for life
that's kind of what we thought um and
then we kind of made this we're like
well we'll set a goal for 2025 you know
and so that was our goal was to pay off
student loans by 2025 but then we came
across the you know ramsay method and
started we got on board with each other
and
here we are in 2022 we were able to pay
it off three years earlier than what our
goal was we still make a quarter million
dollars a year but you're not a payment
in the world
except our mortgage yes the little
mortgage yeah yeah okay yeah and we're
on track to paying off that um mortgage
and this year this year yeah wow
nice i'm so proud of you yeah
it's gotta feel like you lost 300 pounds
oh definitely yeah yeah i was coming
home stressed and having to deal with
everything at covid and everything it
was
it was bringing home all the angst from
work and it was just not worth it but
the one thing i wanted to mention was uh
realizing that uh yes i could get out of
debt quickly once i ran the numbers but
i had to really humble myself because i
had a lot of pride and i was like oh i
don't want to give up all these
resources that i've accumulated
and uh you know realizing i need to
humble myself before god and you know
the fact that you showed us that path
was
so helpful i mean from a stress
perspective
your mind has to be
clearer your quality of patient care had
to go up uh i think it did yes i mean it
bothers me a lot that the entire medical
community is stressed out
it's a great point oh yeah it's just
it's a little bit scary you know some of
the most stressed out and debt laden
people are the people that work on our
bodies oh my god that scares me oh but
yeah i'm so glad you guys are free
you have an area of specialty you work
in or uh family medicine just general
practice yeah that's great wonderful
very cool all right so um my gosh
for for you guys home you know you know
not caring what other people think
not measuring by other people's
yardstick sets you free oh yeah you said
this is what we want we want to be free
more than we want to own that thing oh
yeah definitely it's a trade-off yeah
and now you're free now you get to live
like no one else and you'll be able to
do anything with this kind of income
long term you're young you've still got
a lot of time to do this so
very very cool yeah i quick question uh
wayne when whitney comes to you and
proposes this
i mean this is a this is the
stay-at-home mom with all the kiddos
right she's going i want to downsize i
want to sell this nicer home we're going
to go in this small i mean were you
immediately like oh wow or were you
hanging on a little bit were you shocked
what was the reaction i was definitely
hanging on i mean
i was worried that since she has to be
home with the kids moving to a smaller
home i knew that would be stressful and
so it took me a while to uh
i guess to come around yeah by a while a
month or a month and a half wow okay and
whitney i got to give you some love we
get calls all the time people think they
got to have a bigger house with more
kids and you've actually downsized for
this journey and it's absolutely worth
the chaos isn't it oh it is yes it's
it's worth it every yeah and it's not
permanent hello yes that's right that's
the thing it's not permanent but you
know we no longer have the debt so
that's that's the big thing and so we're
able the money that we get now we're
actually able to save or we're able to
invest in our kids future their college
future you know and that is so like
reassuring to us that we you know the
money that we're taking in now is no
longer going to our student loans and
that's what it was but now it's going to
our you know bank account our
investments or our children and so that
is just so freeing it is you have so
much um you now have control of your
greatest wealth building tool yeah which
it turned out was not the accumulation
of stuff it was your income yes very
true and you got rid of they got rid of
that that mythology way to go guys
so proud of you very cool you're a neat
young couple
very very neat all right we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
you're going to be that if you're not
already very very soon you're on your
way
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give to someone
maybe you can start them on this journey
and the financial peace university class
for a year a uh membership for that for
one year if you've not been through it
go through it if you have uh give it to
somebody the brand new videos are up
it's the best class we've ever done it's
up right now and so thank you guys all
right we're going to get the kiddos in
for the debt free scream one of their
names and ages
we have lachlan he is five
logan's three williams
all right whitney and wayne and the
tribe 350 000 paid off in four months
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three three two
one
we're dead
they have been practicing way to go guys
on behalf of the little sister well done
well done man that's a beautiful story
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five ken that last debt free
stream was
incredible um
but what was so interesting is that that
uh
it illustrates how fast you can turn
your life around
sometimes it takes a little time
but how fast the whole process can begin
and a hundred percent of that is between
your ears that's correct you have to
decide yeah you're not worried about you
know once he saw something he believed
in once she saw something they believed
this i would rather have this than where
i am
then you no longer care what
you know whoever's going to say
your broke friend from college your
broke brother-in-law that votes the
wrong way you know you don't really care
what they say once you reach that point
because you're like
you're not giving me any money anyway
yeah i want to be free
and once they said okay freedom is the
trade-off
they went for it fast and hard and the
contentment came man oh yeah she goes to
a house with four little tiny babies oh
yeah uh that's half or less the size
well you know it speaks to motivation
you know they get to that point and you
just laid it out beautifully or you
decide okay what do i want my desired
future to be do i want to be free of all
this debt all the stress the practice
you know he's running maybe he's running
a practice get all these things
and then you go okay wait a second on
the other side of the sacrifice of
getting rid of my really nice home in
the really nice neighborhood downsizing
dealing with the chaos all of the things
on the other side of this is true
contentment and peace then you get
motivated you go okay i'm willing to
sacrifice to put up with that for a
season and you pointed out it's only for
a season yeah and there but there's a
trade-off
there's always pain yep
you know live like no one else so that
later you can live
and give like no one else back in the
golden edge of golf
if you want to call it that um the great
gary player was one of the long drivers
of the day
and uh the old story goes that he was
standing here at the uh driving range
you know just whipping that ball out
there 300 yards 300 yards 320 yards this
kind of stuff back when no one did that
i mean there was no d shin bow in those
days right that's right and um
you know a guy came up and said you know
i'd give anything
to hit a ball like that i guess he
caught mr player at a bad moment yeah
because he turned around and kind of let
into him as the story goes and says no
you wouldn't the guy goes yeah i
wouldn't he goes oh no you wouldn't you
wouldn't go the driving range and hit
balls until your hands bleed and then
you tape your hands and then you hit
balls for another three hours after that
you wouldn't do that day in and day out
week in and week out month in and month
out year after year until you had
calluses over your hands until you could
swing a club like that you won't pay
that price to win you'd rather watch me
do it and that's why i'm here yeah and
you know but that's kind of smart i like
answer but uh but it's also accurate
that's right you know you you you know
you can't say i'd give anything to be
thin like that uh yeah you would you can
just give up the pizza yeah you know
back away from the soft drinks uh the
bread table the whatever it is is
killing you
exercise more eat less you know when
you're ready to do the trade-off to get
the win
that's when you'll get the win that's
correct there is no progress absent of
pain it's just not
there's always going to be some pain
emotional pain if you want your marriage
to get fixed it means you have to sit
your butt with a counselor and deal with
some stuff and dig and yeah you got to
give up some things you've been doing
that have been causing that yeah there's
always pain
uh as part of the process to make the
progress you want in any area of your
life certainly financially and we just
have to embrace that it's true in your
career oh my gosh you're gonna have to
you know you're going to have to start
out on the lowest rung of the ladder if
you're making a pivot or if you're
coming out of school you got to pay your
dues that's painful for some people
right you know we did this thing a
thousand years ago i guess i was in high
school which was a thousand years ago
and uh
and i actually think maybe we did it
no we did it with the early versions of
the ramsey personal finance curriculum
you would draw you the teacher the
teacher's guide had a series of jobs
with dollar amounts on them
and they would cut them out and you'd
draw out of a hat and if you drew a good
job you know your budget was going to be
a lot bigger if you drew a not so good
job your budget is going to be smaller
but either way you had you drew and you
know what that's just not how it really
works is it no not at all no you don't
get to draw no you do not doctor oh yeah
you got to learn and then you got to go
to school forever oh yeah then you can
say doctor right but you're not gonna it
just doesn't you don't just draw it out
of a hat you gotta go do it it's true no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
that couple was impressive they were
they were you talk about the pain i mean
the early days of you starting this
company
i mean that's painful yeah i'd give
anything to heaven you know you're so
lucky that one does piss me off exactly
luck had nothing to do with no no
unbelievable hard work over over 30
years in god's blessings
that's the only thing luck had nothing
to do with it god chose to grow a crop
after we chose to plant it correct
and those two things work together you
work like it all depends on you you pray
like it all depends on god and both show
up luck had nothing to do with it it's
true so don't talk to me about luck and
please don't tell me that the democrats
built this please i'll just really get
upset then it's a problem um a few of
them worked here but you know that's not
not that many but a few of them and a
few of them still do they sneak in the
building sometimes i'm kidding i love
you democrats i love you he does he
probably he does i promise i do i really
do tom is with us thomas in green bay
wisconsin hey tom what's up
hi gentlemen how are you doing today
great man how can we help
well my employer is terminating the
pension that they while they actually
stopped the pension in like 1996 but uh
now they are creating their hands of it
and i need to
do something with it by august 5th and
we either have to to take a lump sum an
annuity or defer pain until later i want
to take the lump sum yes you do you want
to invest it yes you do i and it's a
critical investment for me
i'm 57 years old absolutely you do
that's exactly what you want to do
here's the thing when you die a pension
dies with you
right okay so how much money is this
lump sum
53 000 okay good good you don't want to
lose 53 000 upon your death so we're
going to roll it your lump sum you can
roll it into an ira it'll have no taxes
and
53 000 is not going to make you rich
and it's not going to make you poor if
you lost it all but you're not going to
do either one so it's great with this i
hope you do some other things that make
you rich
but it's it's a good start i'll take it
if you send it to me i'm not mad about
it but uh it's not 500 000 it's not 5
000 right so uh what i would do is i
would sit down with one of our smart
investor pros people we recommend we're
not in the investment business if you
didn't know tom we just have a group of
brokers out there a group of financial
guys that and gals that we endorse that
we have vetted
and you can choose from among them by
clicking smart vester at ramsey
solutions and here's the thing
you're feeling the weight of this
decision
anytime we have a decision that has a
lot of weight to it
the way to get comfortable with it is
study
knowledge and sit down with that smart
investor pro and tell them i'm worried
about this and the only way my worries
going to go away is the more i know so
you got to teach me a lot between now
and august the 5th
i need to learn a lot you don't have to
be don't need to get a master's degree
in finance but you need to know what a
mutual fund is how it works what the
track record is i'm going to buy this
mutual fund like the one of the first
mutual funds i ever bought tom gave me a
lot of peace because it was one of the
first times i'd ever done it and it was
a it's a mutual fund that today is over
80 years old
and it's got like a 12.2 percent rate of
return over 80 years average
that gave me a lot of comfort and out of
the 80 years or whatever it is 83 years
however old the thing is there's only
like uh i don't know
12 years or something it was down the
rest of time it was up wow see when you
start getting that knowledge then the
weight of the decision starts coming off
your shoulders and you go oh okay it's
like buying a house in a good
neighborhood the trees are big it's
predictable we don't know if this is
going to work we do know this is going
to work because it's worked for a long
time and so we're looking at track
record and history and you're studying
and learning and that will remove a lot
of the stress do not transfer the stress
from your shoulders to the other guy and
go well he picked it out no you're going
to pick it out you're going to learn you
need a
investment person with the heart of a
teacher
so click smart master pro smart vester
at ramsey solutions you'll find one of
the smart mr pros and you'll be just
fine tom just learn learn learn it'll
give you peace
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth do work that they really
love and create actual
amazing relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five ken is the host of the ken
coleman show heard on 75 radio stations
multiple millions on podcast and has
done two best-selling books so far all
in the area of career helping you find
the job the career that you love triple
eight eight two five five two two
five thomas is with us thomas is in
boston mass what's up thomas
hi uh thank you so much for taking my
call um
well i'm and i'm glad you're doing
better than you deserve i love that
phrase
um
i'm 59 years old and about a year ago my
father passed away and we sold his house
and i received a portion
of the funds
along with my brothers about a hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars
um about five years ago i went through a
divorce and i bought a small house
uh that's appreciated in value about a
hundred and twenty eight thousand
dollars so my question is um i have
let's see um
i'll just kind of give you the lay of
the land i have about a hundred thousand
dollars in my ira at my present job
earned uh
fifty
three thousand dollars in a rollover
from a previous job
a small pension that will also come
from my early present job if i stay
there until i retire
um
and 75 000 dollars in cash in
my bank account that's the other chunk
of money that came from the sale of the
house i gave an investment company about
a hundred thousand dollars to invest
and and then lately i've been thinking
you know
i've been listening to your show for a
couple of months now and the thing that
really struck me lately is just even
though i'm older and i never made a ton
of money in my lifetime i've always been
a working artist and the company i work
for presently i'm a i'm a video 3d
artist i do a lot of animations and
prototypical
uh videos for
engineers
scientific videos
anyway
um
at this at this time i thought to myself
you know i bought this house but gee i
could maybe i could pull the money back
out of uh the investment company that i
i put the money into i know the market
is not doing that great and but you've
i've also heard you say that
if um you know you pull money out you
lose it's like jumping off the roller
coaster so you lose even though the
market's gone down in value a little bit
how much is your mortgage so my mortgage
is um 13
13
40 a month no no no i watched the
balance
oh the balance to uh 200 000 left the
house i bought for
278 000 at the time okay so if you use
your cash and your hundred thousand
dollar investment you wouldn't have
enough to pay it off
no i but i'd come pretty close if i if i
paid
let's see the hundred that i gave them
are close to it and the 75 that's in the
bank um
i'd probably be forty thousand thirty
five million forty thousand out from
paying it off um and what do you mean in
the next year or two i make about 80 000
per year
okay and when did you put 100 000 into
investments
um i started it in january
yeah so you got 80 000 now
yeah it's gone down a bit yeah and
that's what i was wondering whether to
just leave it in there let it come back
and find some other way
and just start doubling up like crazy or
whatever and paying the house off myself
so what i would do is take the 75 cash
and throw it at the house
and then i would start throwing money
out of your income at the house as fast
as you can like you were saying put
another 40 on there
and yeah by then maybe the market will
have come back up a little
yeah and you know if you got back up to
100 that'd be the time and you were
within striking range
but there's it um
because you're going to lock in a 20
loss right now
uh you bought high and so low i wouldn't
lock it in because it doesn't get you
out of debt if it paid off everything
i'd be tempted but you still got the
house payment
yeah and so what i would do is just wait
so i'd throw 75 out today and i'd throw
everything else i could get my hands on
at it until
and then over the next months
six months or something watch the stock
market uh recover and if it gets back up
in that hundred range and it gets within
where that hundred will pay off your
house because you paid it down far
enough
then i
when i when he'll pay off the house
that's when i pull it out
okay when it can pay it off yeah because
you've paid the house down
to where this account is at 100 or so
and it's going to back up to 100.
you see what i'm saying
i'm sorry okay so 175 does not pay off
your house you owe how much no
i owe 200 000 left okay so you need to
pay 25 000 down on this house
before out of your income before you
cash out this investment
okay
and then if the investment was gotten
big enough by that time that it will pay
off the house 100
that's when i would pay it off
okay
and throw 75 at the house today
that's the mix of the thing
so
yeah
we don't time the market can we're not
trying to jump in and jump out of the
market on the um
uh
based on what's going on uh and so if if
this would pay off his house hundred
percent i'd probably do it even with the
market down
but it doesn't he still got the cash
flow drain
he still got the 1300 bucks a month
going with his mortgage
and all we did was just lose 20 percent
lost 20 000 bucks meantime we could let
that roller coaster ride on through the
ride and see how it does a little bit
while we're doing this and that's why
i'm trying to figure that out for the
for the new listener the new viewer uh
let's say that the market does recover
which we believe it will obviously gets
it back up right
why pay off the house uh versus just
continue to invest at a hundred thousand
why would you recommend that well uh
several reasons one is that uh all of
our study of millionaires
and all of our anecdotal interaction
with them for 30 years indicates that
one of the key things that causes your
net worth to get a million to 10 million
your first 10 million dollars is a paid
off house
number one there's a whole lot of data
that indicates that that's a big part of
people getting to a high level of net
worth which helps you have stability the
second reason you have a paid off house
you're 59 years old by the time we
finish this routine he's gonna be in his
60s
somewhere okay now you do not want to
enter your golden years
with a mortgage
uh having a paid for home gets rid of
the largest line item in your budget
the biggest the most expensive thing in
the household budget is typically a
mortgage
and
if you don't have those expensive things
in your budget it requires a lot less to
live you've got a lot higher quality of
life you can do a lot of other things
that you wanted to do
in your golden years but couldn't do
because you're strapped to a stinking
house i mean you won't be 82 years old
paying a mortgage
people do they get stuck in that but
that's not that's not a target that's
not a desired future
so good question
open phones here on the ramsey show
we're glad you're with us the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this
thursday we're going to be hosting a
free
live stream event called the real estate
reality check there's rumors of the
market crashing rumors of it going up
rumors and rumors and rumors and
everybody's got an opinion everybody's
got a feeling and feelings and opinions
won't get you there boys and girls
so what you need are facts
and then you can decide for yourself
i predicted a whole lot of things
correctly and i predicted a few things
incorrectly
i said very resolutely in 2008 we were
not going into a recession and i was so
wrong as unbelievable
we obviously went into one
uh
and uh
you know this time last year i told you
there was gonna be a bunch of inflation
i was right i picked that one okay uh
the real estate thing i generally know
because i grew up in that business and
i've got a degree in that which involves
economics and other stuff and so i feel
really really good about analyzing the
data there but i'll put the data out
there for you i'm going to show you this
charts and graphs and rachel cruz and
george campbell and i are going to
discuss it um and uh rachel will be
there she everybody likes rachel so that
should be the nice part of the night her
and george yeah and um then i'll just be
you know uh the other guy and so anyway
spoiler alert the real estate market's
not going to crash but we're going to
show you exactly why we think that and
then you can decide you decide what you
want to do
you know some of you have already made
up your mind but you made up your mind
based on
fear
and having a discussion smoking pot with
your brother-in-law
and you know you didn't have any facts
that you were dealing with and you were
just you know you're just high and had
an opinion you know and that there's a
whole lot of people running around and
then they go buy a house the next week
or don't buy a house the next week
because of this and that's just dumber
than a rock man so i don't mind if you
disagree with me but at least be
intelligent while you're doing it okay
at least have to have it based on facts
not on feelings and and bogus
you know red herrings that you're
chasing on some conspiracy theory don't
cut it so here we go we're going to talk
you through every bit of it and then you
can agree or disagree if you've got
someone that's kind of scared but they
need some hope we're going to show them
why there is real reason to have hope
um
not just because we're pollyanna but
because there's actual facts and data
that there's reason to have hope and so
we're going to show you what's going on
yeah there's some crap going on out
there man i mean it's a mess
we're probably going into a recession
not officially yet
we've definitely got inflation that
we've not seen in decades right now
is that going to stick around we've got
higher interest rates i say high they're
not higher they're higher they're not
high it's still six percent is not
exactly high you're talking to a guy
they're listening to guys sold real
estate when rates were 18 and 15
in the early 80s people were mind blown
buying houses and there's credit card
interest rates on houses
and so you know it's
you know six percent is not high but it
is higher than three yeah and so it's
enough reason to be bothered about it so
that's the kind of stuff we're gonna be
covering it's this thursday july the
14th at 7 00 pm tell your friends it's
free
just go and register to watch it uh
we'll be broadcasting it from our
website at ramseysolutions.com
slash reality check to get signed up
we'll send you the link and voila you'll
be able to do it and make things happen
there good stuff all right melissa's
with us in mesa arizona hi melissa how
are you
dave i'm better than i deserve how are
you just the same what's up
all right so i'm on baby step 3b but my
question is about baby step four i'm a
part of arizona's retirement pension
which is a required 12 percent and so
i've already been contributing anyway
through my baby steps one two and three
you had to but what i'm wondering
is if i should start my baby step four
by investing the difference in the
market right now because it's down and
how much should i be doing to get to my
15
okay well here the
you know you have to do the 12 as you
said it's mandatory it's not an option
so we should recommend as you know in
baby step four putting 15
of your income so you're certainly going
to put in at least three percent right
okay 12 plus three to get you to 15
right okay now
i discount
the
pension
somewhat for two reasons
one is you have absolutely no control
over what it's invested in
they decide
now i'm not i'm not predicting that the
arizona pension is weak and it's gonna
go you know gonna go belly up and you're
gonna lose your money i don't think
that's gonna happen okay
but i but you don't have any choices
here and when you don't have choices you
don't have control of your destiny so i
don't i don't i can't mathematically
treat that the same as when you put
money in your 401k and you have the
choice
follow me
yeah the second thing is that pensions
are more highly regulated
in that because so many of them did go
broke back in the day
that the uh
the federal regulations on pensions
require them to invest so much more
conservatively than you would or i would
that the rate of return on the pension
sucks
and so most pensions at about seven yeah
about seven is where they're going to
sit
uh they're gonna invest just
aggressively enough to get up to that
and after that they've met their
guidelines and they don't want they
don't take any chances and they don't
want anybody leaning in on them from the
government red golf rigs looking out
over their shoulder or something like
that so you can about depend on seven
where you know my mutual funds i've been
investing for 30 years i've averaged
about 12.
okay right so that that's a big
difference uh if you got 11 maybe it'd
still be a big difference right we've
averaged what the s p 500 has
so
uh for the because it's not going to
perform as well and i don't have control
over it i don't want to count it at a
full 12 percent so i'd put in at least
five percent more
in addition to this
and if you want to get it
yeah yeah and so you'd be at 17
effectively instead of 15 okay but we're
kind of discounting that 12 a little
because you don't have control of it and
because it's got a poor rate of return
that's how i view it now you can do
whatever you want to do but that's just
that's my analysis of it and what i
would do if i woke up in your shoes that
kind of a thing and ken we're seeing in
the job market the pensions are just
about gone
yeah and and here's the deal
do we trust state governments to really
make the best financial decisions it
depends what state you live in you know
but there are some where it's highly
questionable and so yeah illinois good
point no illinois yeah you know geez
yeah you can mess up christmas up there
people never see anything like it
um so but um and this really hedging
protection is what the advice you're
giving there it's like hey but some
states i mean like tennessee we have a
man we have a constitutional you know
uh
a mandate for the for the budget to be
balanced that's right and so tennessee
by governance by by the documents in
places run better that's right than some
of these areas so that pension is going
to be a lot more safe in that state
than it is in in illinois that's right
um
and so but that's the uh
and i have no idea what arizona is doing
i i have a respect for the state of
arizona so i suspect it's probably
pretty good much more i don't have
anything to base i don't know
i haven't looked at it that's right and
to your point though even private you
know private sector the pension is
really a thing of the past and so having
a real solid strategy that we teach here
we were meeting recently going over the
numbers long term the advice you just
gave i mean double check him on this
folks he's right uh if you just look at
that investment strategy that we teach
at ramsey solutions
it's going to pay off long term and so
don't rely on just the pension i think
that's incredible advice that's extra
not a whole lot extra but it's a little
bit of gravy and as you get your house
paid off and you're in baby step seven
you know you're going to max out
everything everything so um and you're
gonna have really sweet stuff aside from
the pension and then as you said at that
point the pension really becomes crazy
yeah but um you know when i started uh
30 years ago like 70 of the company
still had pensions oh yeah now it's
probably ten percent what is the reason
for that just did it wasn't economically
smart for the companies i'm guessing
well the 401k came in like a rage yeah
certainly and guess what you're not
putting money in if you're the company
that's correct 1k nowadays about 80
percent of people 85 percent of the
companies match something on the 401k
but still costs the company nowhere near
what a pension as much as funding a
pension as a benefit wow and so the cost
goes way down
for the employer
and the result is actually better for
the team member it's correct you know
and when it's all said and done now the
difference with the pension is you know
in her case she's mandatory has to put
it in yep that's correct but in a lot of
cases the employer is completely
furnishing in the old days the pension
but those days are pretty much gone so
the bad news is it's up to you the great
news is it's up to yes
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
we love doing debt-free screams we extra
love doing debt-free screams in the
lobby of ramsey solutions and we extra
extra love doing debt-free screams in
the lobby of ramsey solutions one is one
of our own yes team members and that's
true today dylan foley is with us and uh
his wife kate they are part of our team
part of our family here at ramsey uh
have been for just a little while but
have gotten to be debt-free
congratulations guys thank you thank you
so proud of y'all very cool all right
tell people how much debt you paid off
we paid off 120 000 very cool and how
long did this take took three years good
for you and i won't ask your income
because half your team is standing
around that would be completely tacky
and unfair it's probably tacky and
unfair that i do it to other people but
i'm not gonna do it to you so uh way to
go guys now tell us your story you
started here how long ago i started in
september dave okay just the other day
it feels like
coming up on your first year though
coming up and what do you do here remind
everybody i work with smart dollar i'm a
relationship manager with smart dollar
which means you
i manage relationships work with clients
in the hr world
with with different companies
all over the u.s yeah where companies
are wanting to put smart dollar which is
our
our program in as an hr benefit to have
their employees learn how to handle
money it's called smart dollar and uh
has the every dollar product tied with
it and everything and so
everything from small businesses to huge
companies like costco or t have had this
all their employees go through it and
pay for it as a benefit for their team
and you help people do that yes okay
just making sure i get this right
because i'm supposed to turn this into
an ad for your boss right okay so just
making sure we get this dialed in way to
go man so proud of y'all okay 120 000 in
debt was what kind of debt so it was a
little bit of credit card uh a little
bit of medical debt and the big chunk of
it was uh student loans
yeah your student loans yeah okay so
what do you do i'm a nurse oh very cool
okay so how much of the 120 was student
loans it was about a hundred okay yeah
how long you all been married uh three
years
okay all right and this uh did you move
here to take this job for tonight yes
yes from from the bronx oh wow yeah
yeah small one small from hot pretzels
to grits
[Laughter]
nice well played dave very well played i
like that that's good why the cow guys
so
obviously it's working out for you you
stuck around yes so good we're glad to
have you good stuff and uh you had to be
well you're well into this journey
almost two years into the journey when
you come here so tell us your story how
did you end up here and how does that
weave into the whole story yeah so dave
i was a full-time musician uh for a
little while uh back in my single days
and uh i was playing um all over and i
was actually on a trip up to buffalo
with with an accordion player and he uh
he said dylan you know we got the seven
hour trip do you mind if i uh catch up
on some talk radio i'm like yeah sure
sure so uh so he puts on the ramsey show
and uh and we listen to that for big
with accordion players
a wild crazy group
the accordion people love us yeah we got
a real we got that that group dialed in
what do you play i play the fiddle oh
yeah that's perfect yeah yeah yeah
that's great good accompaniment okay so
cool yeah all right and what made you
decide to move to nashville oh my gosh
well uh i part of it was getting out of
new york during the cove at times oh
kate kate being a nurse and uh yeah you
were stuck weren't you yeah yeah little
of it up there you know we we started
working the program in 2019 after we got
married and then
2020 covet hit and it was just uh it was
hard it was really hard you know uh kate
had um the two miscarriages and uh it
was just uh it was a really hard time
and we got covered and we got covered
too yeah of course right and there's not
and there's not a lot of fiddle and
accordion work at that time either this
is true this is true yeah yeah it
definitely dried up the music stuff wow
so uh nashville is a whole complete
culture change
so are you refugees or is this now home
oh this is home this is home
so okay very very cool not to mention
dave there's a fiddle every other house
here in tennessee yeah he has no trouble
no trouble finding other fiddle players
now those are corny and guys they're a
little more rare
all right so you he he turns on talk
radio and you come home and tell her
we're gonna try this
well yeah yeah so that you know i was
this was before kate i was i was oh i
was on tour and i i started working the
plan myself
and um managed to um
get out of debt at the time and then we
met and we got married and then we
started working the plan so yeah okay
all right and so you knew what to do
with that hundred thousand dollars in
student loan when you met her it was it
was go time yes it was good came on and
didn't talk didn't have to talk you into
it i guess not really no it was ready
all right
very cool all right now that you've done
it what do you tell people because you
get to tell people every day on your job
yeah well you know what's the key to
getting out of debt yeah yeah um i would
say communication perseverance sacrifice
and prayer
oh
so um
dylan write that down that's your sales
pitch
right there that she just dialed it in
for you yeah okay that's what you can
yeah next time you're talking to an hr
manager some company's deciding whether
to have this this is what they do
and yeah because this is a real world
that exactly works say it one more time
communication
perseverance sacrifice and prayer that's
it that's a formula for success right
there in anything but and certainly in
getting out of debt yeah so dylan what
do you say
uh well definitely the prayer prayer uh
hope and don't worry that's what i was
that's what i was that was a big mantra
during all of this pray hope and don't
worry yeah be anxious for nothing yeah
well were you i love that let's stay
there when you say don't worry what were
you guys fighting worry against what
were you worried about
oh man well it was it was just a
constant push of you know can we can we
do this right it was 120 000 it felt
like a bear whenever
and then in the middle of a bear attack
you get like two miscarriages lose your
jobs covered
and a government that's gone crazy
exactly but this is a hard time to have
a bear attack yeah
yeah
man wow
wow that is perseverance right there it
really is you know it's interesting you
know this the smart dollar is an
incredible benefit for people and the
data shows that when people are
debt-free and don't have money worries
they're able to come to work and
actually focus on the task at hand and
to excel both of you on the other side
of this uh what is it like for you now
to be a nurse uh
to do what you do without the stress of
debt what's it like oh so much freedom
there's so much freedom in it it's so
refreshing
you know to not have that worry and you
don't have to stay in a toxic
environment
you've got choices yeah you know and you
don't you know they start going
cray-cray you know at it wouldn't happen
here but it could happen at the other
place
you can just go see ya
yeah oh man it's really true though when
you're not worried uh about debt you go
i can get a paycheck somewhere else i'm
not going to stay in a place that
doesn't value me yeah it changes your
career choices man i'm so proud of you
all you're going to be amazing you've
got the whole team down here to cheer
you on life is good very very cool very
very well done well we've got copies of
all the books and stuff for you you know
that drill baby steps millionaires and
total money makeover all to help you and
uh you've already been through financial
peace but we'll give you another one you
can give that to somebody as a a free
giveaway one of your buddies or
something and uh so we're so glad you're
here on the team you're obviously sharp
young couple honored to have you great
thank you so much very very very well
done all right dylan and kate from
nashville oh wait wait a minute there's
is is uh no sheer k i'm sorry dylan and
kate i got it backwards okay i'm losing
my mind i thought there was a kid i'm
i'm looking at the parentheses wrong i'm
sorry on my notes oh my bad all right
dylan and kate
part of the ramsey team
goodness gracious dave 120 000 paid off
in three years we're not going to tell
their income count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
yeah
that's how it's done
you know that is a real life example
of the migration that has occurred in
our country
um to where she can now be a nurse
and he can work and he's in a town where
there's lots of musicians
and uh they wouldn't have been here if
it hadn't been for
you know several of those things that
ganged up on them but they said hey we
gotta go do something different
and look at them starting a new life
good stuff good stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
our scripture today psalms 149 4 for the
lord takes delight in his people
he crowns the humble with victory
eleanor roosevelt said we do not have to
become heroes overnight just a step at a
time
meeting each thing that comes up
seeing it not as dreadful as it appears
discovering we have the strength to
stare it down
now
you know it's funny i think eleanor
roosevelt probably had better quotes
than her husband oh without a question
she gets more print uh after her life
and presidency
his presidency and see there's a good
democrat
see we we
we're good to democrats sometimes so
gotta have some fun with this but now my
favorite quote of hers and i i don't
know if i can get it exactly right is
the um
great minds are small minds talk about
people
uh mediocre minds talk about events and
great minds talk about ideas
yeah or something about like that that's
very close to it um but yeah this you
know
talking about people mm-hmm you know
that's always the smallest mind in the
room yeah and the big mind the the the
noble mind will be talking about ideas
you know discussing ideas yeah arguing
ideas
and uh instead of just name calling and
flamethrowing yeah chris is with us
chris is in hendersonville tennessee hi
chris how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i i i call you with i feel like
it's a good problem to have we me and my
wife we were married uh three months now
or so we have a two-year-old daughter i
opened a business about going on about
one calendar a year ago and
i mean it's uh i'm i mean i'm making
more money than i would ever thought
possible good for you my question for
you is
i have
you know i've only got really three
debts i have a car 65 000 and a car for
her i have a vehicle myself thirty three
thousand dollars when i own it and we
have a house uh 405 000 on the house the
only catch on the house is being
self-employed the house is a 5-1 armed
mortgage at current current rate is 4.25
we bought it about uh actually right
when we got married we got buried moved
into our house uh so we're three months
into the house
um
my question what do you make about
uh my wife makes about 55 000 i make
about 410 000 now
why do you still have hard debt
well here my well so here's my thing the
first year that i was in business uh
you know i bought equipment i bought
things to help my business pay for it
cash and the rest of it i was just
redneck rich we went out to fancy
dinners we went everywhere we bought
everything four hundred thousand dollars
worth
yeah well not i mean i have about sixty
thousand in savings
you're saying 400 000 was your profit on
the business last year that you paid
taxes on
no well yes uh 400 000 was my income i
paid
all i have overhead now is fuel and you
know that's taxes i'm saying i'm a
single employee i don't have an
employees or anything okay
so
so how much money do you have any money
yeah i've got about about 60 000 give or
take in the bank sitting there yeah pay
off her car today
okay
and then go pay off the other one pay
off the 33 000 car today and then go pay
her hers off next month
okay my my question essentially was
do i being self-employed uh make i make
very good money now i feel
do i throw everything that i have at the
mortgage being a 5-1
or do i kind of pay it normal or pay it
a little hard and put money in the bank
and then it be towards the end of the
5-1 pay it off real hard and that way if
there is any sort of a recession not
huge i mean how projectable how
projectible stable do you think this
income stream is
um if if i make 400 now and it and we
get a recession i think i may be able to
it may drop down to 220
ish you know about half but i mean
that's still great money i feel yeah but
i mean i'm in the concrete business so i
mean there long as there's still some
sort of construction we still are going
to be doing work okay wow
and you're again i'm going to verify
because i want to make sure i've got
your business acumen straight you're
saying this 400 is taxable
income that you paid taxes on
yeah i make about 1800 a day it's not
your grocery store it's not your growth
1800 is your gross revenue
yeah growth you have business expenses
out of that what is your net profit
uh i i literally only pay fuel fuel and
taxes is what i paid per day and then
the rest is profit for me okay
all right wow that's wonderful
okay so because whatever the equipment
is involved you've already paid for it
and so it's not only yeah i paid cash
for that was that i got some repairs
here or there or whatever on that but
nothing major
yeah the first year was paying the first
year i mean the equipment's a hundred
and 150 thousand dollars okay here's
what i want you to do all right you
you've
explained this uh beautifully and
ken i think he's analyzed it well and
that um he feels like he
uh uh just reached up and got the gold
ring you know i mean and it's almost
surprising to you that you're making
this kind of money i hear that in your
voice
oh gosh i'm i'm shocked yeah and you
feel blessed and that's a good that's a
good position to be emotionally now what
i want that to lead you to do is instead
of letting that lead you to be sloppy
i want it to i want you to feel the
weight
of the responsibility of that kind of
money
and which is kind of the opposite end of
the spectrum of redneck rich
okay
yes sir and so that's going to involve
like i'm going to start treating this
very very seriously
like i'm a rich guy
because you are
okay and now i've got a now what is the
smartest thing i can do so that when
this story is over you have 20 million
dollars
and if you'll behave
and and have a nice life i'm not talking
about live in a cave and collect lent
but i am talking about you know just
behave and and be
diligent and intentional with every one
of these dollars
you you easily could have 20 million
dollars when this story is finished
okay
but you're gonna have to just do all i
want you to do is just do everything on
purpose instead of waking up with a
financial hangover when this is over
and i totally understand my my question
would have you know yeah and that means
pay off these cars and turn around and
pay this house off you make 400k act
like you make a hundred and let's clear
a bunch of this debt and you're sitting
there with paid for cars paid for house
now there's nothing left to do but
incredible generosity
enjoy life
and invest for the future
i like that and you can do all three
beautifully and i'm talking like 36
months from now
that'll i mean that sounds great
that makes me smile thinking about it
you know but that means you're not going
to be living like you've been living for
the past two years
oh well honestly i ran out of stuff to
buy
i mean i can tell you
i
i listened to you you know on and off
especially before i had a business i i
made about 55 000 a year my wife made
about the same as what she made
and i took a risk up in my business yeah
and
it didn't work so we're talking about
let's just use some round numbers just
to wrap this up okay here's what i'm
doing in my head for you all right i'm
hearing 450
and 400 on the house and 100 on cars did
i hear that right 450 income
that's it okay and so if you lived on
100 that'd be 350
not counting taxes
yeah and that pays off a hundred
thousand dollars worth of cars really
really fast you got some money in the
bank we already paid off some today and
and then it's going to pay off the rest
um
you know you're not going to knock that
house out i'm telling you 36 months is
doable can you see that oh i i
understand
my question was with with you know the
recession with the i don't have any idea
what that's going to do to your business
that's why i was asking you about that
if you think the recession is going to
slow down so much you're not going to
get the concrete work and it's going to
go down to 220. so what keep living on
100 and it slows down how fast you get
the house paid off whoopty doopty house
is still going to be paid for in under
four years
and you're still young and you still
have tremendous upside potential on this
income he's in a sweet spot
yeah he's gonna crush it but you know
i'd get out of that i think the question
is is he want to get out of that arm
quickly or just pay it off before the
arm runs out i just pay it off yeah so
there's your answer you know you pay it
off for it
if you're going to take 10 years to pay
it off go get it refinanced yeah but
you're not you shouldn't if you do this
irresponsible because you make so
stinking much money
clean it up man clean it up you'll be
glad you did you'd be glad you leaned
into this and made this a project treat
it like you're managing a concrete
project knock it out get her done
hey man thanks for the call that puts us
out with the ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you